therefore I can hardly believe I'm here
my name is Terence Mckenna
and my training is basically in
shamanism and botany and ethnography
well until a few minutes ago I thought
that this was a 45 minute gig so you get
to see grace under pressure this evening
actually I'm kidding it doesn't matter
how long it goes we could never get to
the bottom of this stuff nor would we
wish to
[Music]
you know one of the things that has
amazed me with my own personal career
because you know I started out basically
shoveling snow in a cow town in Colorado
and by fate or who knows what come to
the present position and what I noticed
as I traversed levels on a supposed
ladder of success where you would expect
there to be more and more competition
and people and activity actually it gets
emptier and emptier there is nobody
minding the store as far as I can tell
this is why I'm so unsympathetic to
conspiracy theory we could use a few
conspiracies nobody is minding the store
everybody is getting rich personally
rich
[Music]
and so all this fantastic apparatus that
we see around us is really not so much
in the service of channeling liquids
gases but in the service of channeling
spirit out of matter and into the higher
realms where then can be refluxed we
condensed and the lapis philosophorum
the stone the Philosopher's the central
mystery brought to completion
it is upon us every Messiah every
religious ontology every manager of
every booth that this exhibit is
reflected a distorted scintilla of the
spiritual reality of the transcendental
object at the end of time every one of
them is a particular eyes that distorted
image of this transcendental options
into which we are being dissolved
[Music]
so well so what
[Music]